GILBERT STRANG: So
this is the key video
about solving a system of n
linear constant coefficient
equations.
So how do I write
those equations?
Y is now a vector, a
vector with n components.
Instead of one scalar,
just a single number y--
do you want me to
put an arrow on y?
No, I won't repeat it again.
But that's to emphasize
that y is a vector.
Its first derivative,
it's a first order system.
System meaning that there can
be and will be more than one
unknown, y1, y2, to yn.
So how do we solve
such a system?
Then the matrix is multiplying
that y and they equate.
The y's are coupled
together by that matrix.
They're coupled together,
and how do we uncouple them?
That is the magic of
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
Eigenvectors are vectors
that go in their own way.
So when you have an
eigenvector, it's
like you have a
one by one problem
and the a becomes
just a number, lambda.
So for a general vector,
everything is a mixed together.
But for an
eigenvector, everything
stays one dimensional.
The a changes just to a lambda
for that special direction.
And of course, as always, we
need n of those eigenvectors
because we want to take
the starting value.
Just as we did for
powers, we're doing it now
for differential equations.
I take my starting vector, which
is probably not an eigenvector.
I'd make it a combination
of eigenvectors.
And I'm OK because I'm
assuming that I have
n independent eigenvectors.
And now I follow each
starting value c1 x1--
what does that have?
What happens if I'm in
the direction of x1,
then all the messiness
of A disappears.
It acts just like lambda
1 on that vector x1.
Here's what you get.
You get c1, that's
just a number, times e
to the lambda 1t x1.
You see there,
instead of powers,
which we had-- that we had
lambda 1 to the kth power
when we were doing
powers of a matrix,
now we're solving
differential equations.
So we get an e to the lambda 1t.
And of course, next
by superposition,
I can add on the solution
for that one, which
is e to the lambda
2t x2 plus so on,
plus cne to the lambda nt xn.
You can see when, I could
ask, when is this stable?
When do the solutions go to 0?
Well, as t gets
large, this number
will go to 0, provided
lambda 1 is negative.
Or provided its real
part is negative.
We can understand
everything from this piece
by piece formula.
Let me just do an example.
Take a matrix A. In the powers
of a matrix-- in that video
I took a Markov matrix-- let
me take here the equivalent
for differential equations.
So this will give us a
Markov differential equation.
So let me take A now.
The columns of a
Markov matrix add to 1
but in the differential equation
situation, they'll add to 0.
Like minus 1 and 1,
or like minus 2 and 2.
So there is the eigenvalue
of 1 for our powers
is like the eigenvalue 0
for differential equations.
Because e to the 0t is 1.
So anyway, let's find
the eigenvalues of that.
The first eigenvalue is 0.
That's what I'm interested in.
That column adds to 0,
that column adds to 0.
That tells me there's
an eigenvalue of 0.
And what's its eigenvector?
Probably 2, 1 because if
I multiply that matrix
by that vector, I get 0.
So lambda 1 is 0.
And my second eigenvalue,
well the trace is minus 3
and the lambda 1 plus
lambda 2 must give minus 3.
And its eigenvector is-- it's
probably 1 minus 1 again.
So I've done the
preliminary work.
Given this matrix, we've got the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
Now I take u0-- what
should we say for u0?
U0-- y0, say y of 0 to start.
Y of 0 as some number c1
times x1 plus c2 times x2.
Yes, no problem, no problem.
Whatever we have, we take this--
some combination of that vector
and that eigenvector
will give us y of 0.
And now the y of t is c1 e
to the 0t-- e to the lambda
1t times x1, right?
You see, we started with
c1x1 but after a time t,
it's either the lambda
t and here's c2.
E to the lambda
2 is minus 3t x2.
That's the evolution of a Markov
process, a continuous Markov
process.
Compared to the
powers of a matrix,
this is a continuous evolving
evolution of this vector.
Now, I'm interested
in steady state.
Steady state is what
happens as t gets large.
As t gets large, that
number goes quickly to 0.
In our Markov matrix example,
we had 1/2 to a power,
and that went quickly to 0.
Now we have the exponential with
a minus 3, that goes to zero.
E to the 0t is the 1.
This e to the 0t equals 1.
So that 1 is the signal
of a steady state.
Nothing changing, nothing
really depending on time,
just sits there.
So I have c1x1 is
the steady state.
And x1 was this.
So what am I thinking?
I'm thinking that
no matter how you
start, no matter what y
of 0 is, as time goes on,
the x2 part is
going to disappear.
And if you only have the
x1 part in that ratio 2:1.
So again, if we had
movement between Y1 Y2
or we have things
evolving in time,
the steady state is--
this is the steady state.
There is an example of
a differential equation,
happen to have a Markov matrix.
And with a Markov
matrix, then we
know that we'll have
an eigenvalue of -
in the continuous case and a
negative eigenvalue that will
disappear as time goes forward.
E to the minus 3t goes to 0.
Good.
I guess I might just add a
little bit to this video, which
is to explain why is
0 an eigenvalue when
whenever-- if the columns added
to 0, minus 1 plus 1 is 0.
2 minus 2 is zero.
That tells me 0
is an eigenvalue.
For a Markov matrix empowers
the columns added to 1 and 1
was an eigenvalue.
So I guess I have now two
examples of the following fact.
That if all columns add
to some-- what shall
I say for the sum, s for
the sum-- then lambda
equal s is an eigenvalue.
That was the point from
Markov matrices, s was 1.
Every column added to 1
and then lambda equal 1
was an eigenvalue.
And for this video,
every column added
to 0 and then lambda
equal 0 was an eigenvalue.
And also, this is another
point about eigenvalues,
good to make.
The eigenvalues
of a transpose are
the same as the
eigenvalues of A.
So I could also say if
all rows of A add to s,
then lambda equal
s is an eigenvalue.
I'm saying that the eigenvalues
of a matrix and the eigenvalues
of the transpose are the same.
And maybe you would like to
just see why that's true.
If I want the
eigenvalues of a matrix,
I look at the determinant of
lambda I minus A. That gives me
eigenvalues of A. If I want
the eigenvalues of a transpose,
I would look at this
equals 0, right?
This equaling 0.
That equation would
give me the eigenvalues
of a transpose just the
way this one gives me
the eigenvalues of A.
But why are they the same?
Because the determinant of
a matrix and the determinant
of its transpose are equal.
A matrix and its transpose
have the same determinant.
Let me just check
that with A, B, C,
D. And the transpose
would be A, C, B, D.
And the determinant
in both cases
is AD minus BC, AD minus BC.
Transposing doesn't affect.
So this, that is
the same as that.
And the lambdas are the same.
And therefore we can look
at the columns adding to s
or the rows added to s.
So this explains why those
two statements are both true
together because I could look
at the rows or the columns
and reach this conclusion.
That if all columns add
to s-- now why is that,
or all rows add to s?
Let me just-- I'll just
show you the eigenvector.
In this case, A times the
eigenvector would be all ones.
Suppose the matrix is 4 by 4.
If I multiply A by all ones,
when you multiply a matrix
by a vector of
ones, then the dot
product of this row
with that is the sum,
is that plus that plus that
plus that, would be we s.
This would be s because
this first row-- here is
A-- first row of A adds to s.
So these numbers
add to s, I get s.
These numbers add
to s, I get s again.
These numbers add to s.
And these, finally
those numbers add to s.
And I have s times 1, 1, 1, 1.
Are you OK with this?
When all the rows add to
s, I can tell you what
the eigenvector is, 1, 1, 1, 1.
And then the eigenvalue, I
can see that that's the sum s.
So again, for special
matrices, in this case
named after Markov, we are
able to identify important fact
about their eigenvalue, which is
that it's that common row sum s
equal 1 in the case of
powers and s equal 0
in this video's case with--
let me bring down A again.
So here, every
column added to 0.
It didn't happen that
the rows added to 0.
I'm not requiring that.
I'm just saying either
way, A or A transpose
has the same eigenvalues
and one of them is 0
and the other is whatever
the trace tells us, that one.
These collection of useful
fact about eigenvalues
show up when you have
a particular matrix
and you need to know something
about its eigenvalues.
Good, thank you.